le ministre de l'éducation va présenter
demain un premier scénario de fusion de
commissions scolaires et martin vous
avez appris quels seront les grandes
lignes donc de ce scénario est
l'objectif bien sûr c'est de réduire le
nombre de commissions scolaires de faire
les choses autrement
voilà il y à 72 commissions scolaires au
québec
le gouvernement aimerait les ramener à
36 donc en éliminer la moitié
certaines seront épargnés les neuf
commissions scolaires anglophones
seraient touchés mais de façon marginale
nous dit on donc on parle ici d'une
soixantaine de commissions scolaires
francophones en région et autour de
montréal qui devront fusionner ou se
regrouper
la commission scolaire de montréal la
plus grosse au québec devra subir une
restructuration importante
un grand ménage en profondeur s'impose
de 10 temps alors il y aura une
proposition concrète sur la table et
comment ça va se faire est ce qu'il ya
de la place pour des aménagements des
discussions ce n'est pas un scénario
béton la proposition sera présentée à la
fédération des commissions scolaires du
québec demain par le ministre de
l'éducation yves bolduc et les
discussions s'ouvriront les commissions
scolaires sont ouvertes elles ont craint
un moment qu'elle disparaîtrait elles
sont ouvertes donc à la négociation
le ministre de l'éducation devrait
déposer un projet de loi après les fêtes
donc présentation ce scénario demain
après-midi mercier martin sans voix